mais toi encore insouciant quand j'ai vu
ce soit joué alors voilà je présente des
cadres et là tout de suite c'est corey
locke du monde connaît ex téléphone les
groupes de visiteurs
voilà corinne pour le crédit agricole
je le retrouve étrangement fenaille
concurrence en plus je te retrouverai
que fait un tabac
trop longtemps cette raison d'un album
et puis le navire maintenait les clips
la très jolie c'est l'aventuré valtra
voilà ça se passe et retourner être au
top 10 ans et l'album s'appelle comment
vivre
[Musique]
voilà ma première question est pour toi
corinne et voilà elle concerne le cinéma
alors voilà quel est le metteur en scène
français de renommée internationale car
il avait fait un film
il ya trois ou quatre ans qu'on
travaille beaucoup parlé parce qu'il n'y
avait pas beaucoup de dialogues c'est
fini par acheter un peu ses metteurs en
scène vient de se retrouver avec une
cicatrice des douceurs du métro fait à
présent d'aller pour large
pourquoi après 1 pourquoi pas beaucoup
de dialogues je pensais à au dernier
combat de gruissan c
sinon la cicatrice n'a rien à voir avec
des sens car je le connais bien il a pas
de cicatrice ont fait tu connais bien
que il n'a pas jusqu'à présent au fesses
c'est bienvenu en effet voilà tu aurais
tu volais laquelle a répondu bah je
connais la réponse je pense qu'on peut
l'aider tu la connais toi va dire m'a
dit non un film avec pas beaucoup de
dialogues ou alors des dialogues pas
vraiment dans une langue qui exhibe à la
question quel est le metteur en scène ça
va tourner jean jacques annaud bon la
réponse voilà comme réponse de corinne
absolument il se redresse cicatrices
avec un tournant l'ours
absolument la deuxième question c'est
quoi son film c'est la garde à vue
à oui c'est vrai d'accord qui avait pas
monrose dialogue
voilà alors pour toi oliver stone de
metteur en scène de platoon ou de
platoon ou wall street à demander à
madonna
des joué en rôle d'une femme qui était
la femme d'un dictateur latine américain
des années 40
quel est son rôle passé la pensée les
dictateurs sud-américains
oui oui le faisait la guérilla qui ce
faisant non mais tu es femmes de
dictateurs lâche 0 à bari et aussi vers
l'amérique du sud
super et tout serait fin prêt de la
pente pendant que je vois pour essayer
la terreur non obsèques et évita
invitant la comédie musicale qui
s'appelle évita et oliver stone a
demandé à madonna de jouer lé rôle
message chouchou
absolument ils sont enterrés là corinne
pour toi voilà une autre question quel
est guitariste noir célébrissime
vraiment célébrer s'y opposer la
question de maintenant posez la question
je n'ai pas posé la question la question
c'est vrai qu'elle est les guitaristes
noir l émetteur ir un goûteur conclu par
rapport à l'ouverture il avait un bouton
pour sauver les bébés
malheureusement j'ai pas équipés en
question sa mort est détournée décision
voilà effectivement c'est jimmy hendrix
à la france soit pour toi quels sont les
rock stars
quels sont les rock stars qui sont
toutes mortes avant tout en appelant les
partenaires de la cdu en terminant le
prix non voilà ça fait ça fait une
approche n'est plus avant 28 ans non 28
ans 8 ans 10 2 ça ira dès maintenant il
ya plus de filles là tu as tu avais
jamais chopine ça va faire un signe à
l'instinct
aujourd'hui mia drake ça marche 1 des
beatles non c'est pas les seuls à
vaisselle mais ce que j'aime groupe à
200 parade
zhao des balles perdues ou
leur pitance chine c'est françois
berthou oui quelqu'un comme quelqu'un
salut tu es mort c'est lui que mick
jagger a poussé dans l'épisode fort en
bourse avait lieu hier drx brian jones
avait déjà bien sûr en vacances et john
morris jim morrison bakkas d'humoristes
voilà oui ça mais ça fait 5 6-1 voilà
une autre question pour toi corinne
quelle est la top model la météo a calé
le top model qui est en couple avec une
rock star
justement d'entrer alors voilà à
l'effort très forte alors que ça pouvait
être christie brinkley avec billy joel
absolument elle a trouvé jerry hall
absolument que beaucoup plus jeune je
suis resté par la question s'était elle
vient de poser pour une publicité d'un
bouillon de boeuf anglais voilà voilà un
peu comme le viol et non du bouillon de
boeuf
voilà ktm et rené gauvreau mauvrit
l'absolument voilà la dernière question
pour toi
bonsoir quel est le point commun entre
oscar wilde et jim morrison c'est du
hamas est question avis elles sont
plusieurs à buy more c'est un peu plus
dur mais bon quand j'ai enfin - je peux
te mettre sur la voir ce que tous le
deuil sont invités à l'endroit à paris
li côté saint germain des prés voilà
quel est cet endroit avant qu'elles sont
rue des beaux-arts et ses points communs
oui absolument gagner une paire de
lunettes toi je regarde toi va l'arrêter
ratant voir comme ça voilà la semaine
prochaine avec d'autres la question
intelligente très appel
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
inhabituel abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu